hello everyone I'm Ilana and welcome it
to my channel when today I am so stoked
to be able to talk to you guys about
cyberpunk 2077 I so almost an hour of
gameplay and it looks real good
also it's totally going to get banned in
Australia but I digress before we start
talking about the gameplay I wanted to
answer the three most common questions
that I've gotten about it
number one why wasn't it um to the
public when is it going to be shown to
the public I don't know when the rest of
the world is going to get to see some
punk 2077 in action could be as soon as
games calm which is the beginning of it
in Europe that's happening in August but
if I have to guess why they showed it to
press and not to the public it would be
because the public can be kind of jerks
when you show something too soon a very
good example of a thing that happened to
CD Projekt RED themselves is when they
showed witcher 3 footage early and then
people were mad when the game didn't
look like that early footage devs aren't
doing this on purpose they aren't trying
to trick you when something like that
happens basically the more stuff you add
into the game the more stuff you have to
take out because of technical
limitations generally because of
hardware limitations so they could have
shown you the chunk that we had all seen
at e3 this year but fact is that might
not end up being the final version of
that slice of the game seems easy to
just not do it then just kind of wait
number two a lot of people have been
asking me about the fact that it is
first-person and it is this question is
kind of surprising me and will obviously
get into this but this game is not a
reskin of The Witcher 3 this game is not
a cyberpunk futuristic version of The
Witcher 3 some of the core pillars of
the way that CD Projekt make games are
there but it's very very very different
it's a game about shooting people
indoors whereas The Witcher 3 is a game
about casting spells and fighting
monsters outside and the third question
is when do I think it's going to come
out I will straight up say I think this
game is pretty far away from release
what we saw looks so good it was so so
so polished but of course they're only
showing us one part of the game we did
do some open wild stuff and I didn't see
any bugs or glitches but this is the
first game that I've seen
long time where I've been like holy [ __ ]
this is next-level like you watch it
you're like this is the [ __ ] future
of video games
so let's talk about what we actually saw
I'm not gonna remember this perfectly
because I played a lot of games on the
last week so I'm going to try and talk
you through the experience and what I
liked and didn't like about it to the
best of my ability but I do want to say
that I might not be a hundred percent
accurate in case there's something I'm
not recalling so you start out you are
looking for a body in what I would call
a sort of run-down area of night city or
we start off inside a building
it looks grimy but there's so much
detail everywhere it's not like no wall
Simon puck style everything's pretty
light it is during the day and you're
never giving this building it seems
pretty linear and approach but there's a
lot of stuff to look at and a lot of
stuff that's related to well building
specifically like pieces of tech and
hardware that are laying around and
clearly used to augment humans or hack
things or update tech and it's I don't
know even just that first like 15
minutes of us walking around this
building it's just this is just so much
there's so much to look at so then we
get to the first combat encounter and
this one was pretty simple it was just
regular gunplay I want to say it's kind
of like maybe it's because it's on my
mind right now I want to say it's kind
of like rage it's really hard for me to
say if I liked the combat or not because
I didn't get to try it myself but there
were things about it that impressed me a
whole lot and a couple of moments in the
demo where people in the room like
audibly gasped one was seeing an enemy
she threw a wall that's not entirely new
to video games other games have done
that just the way it was done looked so
impressive it didn't look scripted it
looked like they were just trying to
shoot at you they were using a very
powerful weapon and you had to figure
out how to navigate to get around them
because they could shoot through the
wall and they could figure out what you
were they probably had some kind of
ottoman themselves that let them see
through the wall though you sneak around
a side window and shoot them and that
was cool the two out of combat moments
that made people really gasp what a
specific gun that would ricochet so you
could shoot it at a wall and it would
target someone who was behind cover that
was [ __ ] awesome and that angle with
that they were saying was that they
wanted it to be as
difficult for people who wanted it to be
difficult but for people who didn't or
didn't like the shooting elements as
much that you could kind of buy pasta
that you could get weapons that would
make it very very easy for you uh and
then the third con that thing was seeing
the main character V hack into this
specific group of bad guys they were
kind of like a cult who wanted to be as
technologically advanced as possible and
that they were augmenting themselves so
much that they didn't look human anymore
and that was what they wanted to do you
would see like you know they'll eat I've
had like half of his face had been cut
off and and replaced with these just
optical lenses and in that part of the
game he managed to hack one of them and
by going through this kind of giant
network disable all of their guns
because they were all associated with
each other they were also
technologically linked that going
forward you get to a later pod in that
level and a gun wouldn't work because
you would already disabled it until
you're watching these NPCs like be like
what the [ __ ] my guns not working and
trying to figure out why and that was
really cool to see also in that pot
though um you know those blades that we
saw in the first trailer like things
coming out with ohms that's not great
you can get you can wall run and then
like spike one of those blades into a
wall and then sit on the wall and like
shoot down at people that was so cool so
back through the demo we walk can we get
a naked lady she's very naked this is
like pod where we see the world building
coming in as well is V the main
character has a sort of link plug that
she then plugs into the back of this
woman and it lets her itto status so
like if she's alive
whether she desperately needs Hospital
like what her care is and it seems like
this woman was rich and she had some
kind of system that had been disabled
like maybe the rich people have a chip
in them that alerts the authorities if
something is wrong with that vital
science but has have been turned off so
the doctors the the medical service
weren't able to find out they didn't
know that it was in
she so V takes her outside I think she
probably re-enabled it I don't know
about that and then drops her outside
and this is the first time when you see
night city and you're walking out under
this balcony of this [ __ ] huge
building complex that looks like that
building complex in Judge Dredd it's
just like spirals on itself and this is
huge square that looks like it's really
dense the medic shop you put it down and
they take her away and this is the pot
what you like really n tonight city for
the first time so the area that V lives
in specifically I would say a room is
like kinda like Blade Runner II you have
the option to pick different outfits and
your outfits will give you a certain
thing called street cred cuz obviously
being a punk what you wear is really
important depending on your level of
street cred or what kind of street cred
you had I think that that was a variant
it seems like you'll be able to unlock
different side missions and people in
public will react to you differently and
different NPCs will have different
relationships with you
so clothing is a big part of it and you
can in your wardrobe pick which thing
that you want to wear I don't know if
it'll be a kind of situation where sort
of at the end of each day you go to bed
and then that's how you start your day I
imagine it's probably more gta-like than
that but yes there will definitely be
customization options they even though
I'm further back you can choose to play
as a man or a woman you can fully
customize the way that you look your
name is V both emotions voiced but it is
definitely an RPG in that sense and the
next thing that happened I think was
when we went to get upgrades so you take
me out of her apartment and what about
the complex that she's in again like
Judge Dredd it's this I believe they
call it a society of its own it has all
the shops it would need it has thousands
of people living there it looks like
almost like a giant shopping center
complex but there is an outdoor area in
the middle and you walk past all these
neon signs that are actually useful in
the world
so everything that they put in there
they wanted to make sure that in served
a purpose and served a good purpose
so the idea kind of being you would see
a sign and you would it would tell you
where to go and buy a certain thing and
then you would click on it and it would
give you an arrow and show you
to get there there was a lot of stuff
happening like you know we won't post in
this complex area we walk past a gym
there were people weightlifting and
there was a guy who was boxing with a
robot was you know sort of walking pause
so many NPCs doing so many different
things that on screen this is the thing
that makes me think that it was next-gen
it was just so much happening and so
much density just all the time no in a
way that was overwhelming oh that felt
cluttered or anything it was just like
consistently like holy [ __ ] this is one
of the most fully realized video game
worlds I have ever seen
probably that I have ever seen up until
this point so from there are you gonna
meet with your friend Jackie who is
another I guess that just group of cyber
punks
they're watching for people who are
outside of the law enforcement sometimes
also working with the law enforcement it
seems like the RPG elements go pretty
far in that you can choose who you want
to work for how much you want to work
for them and that will change how the
world interacts with you like we had a
random encounter where because we had
worked with one guy who would it be for
these sudden thieves that these guilds
showed up and started shooting at us
while we were driving but upgrades
that's what we did first I think it was
called like a riverbed I don't remember
the actual name but we walked down into
this shop there's a woman be like yeah
he's ready for you just head back and
you walk back there again everything is
just so [ __ ] detailed you said in a
chat and talked about upgrades that you
want to get and what you're getting in
that setting is an optics upgrade so so
like put something on your arm and then
he's just talking to you about what the
changes are going to be the characters
have an interesting or poor and he tells
me that she's going out to black out for
a couple of seconds so like something
approaches the screen goes black and
then comes back on and it seems like she
had been given an optical upgrade that
let's assume so she can like look really
oh he or she whatever can look at things
really directly and get a lot of clarity
but also I think gives you like tagging
abilities in the same way that you know
[ __ ] ride games do but this is just one
upgrade that we saw I imagine there are
a lot of cybernetic upgrades that you
can get you can probably make yourself
as cybernetic as you want
- you can probably you know get
different legs so you run foster in arms
that do different things and I guess
that's how the Mantis thing works I
think it's probably gonna get pretty
crazy I imagine they only showed us this
one thing probably the most basic thing
I think we probably saw the stop at the
game so that happened then we walk out
and we see the open world for the first
time and again just [ __ ] mind blown as
you're walking through the city there
are things that I kept being like I
wonder if that was scripted like an
elevator coming down someone getting off
of it and all the person getting in and
it going back up like did that happen
because we approached the area at the
right time or does that just happen
there
it's just it's colorful and it's clean
for the most part different areas are
not there are areas that are poor in
areas that are bridged so different
parts of the city look different like
some areas and city kind of look like
the stats and ready player one some
Hawks look very pristine and white so
then we jumped in a car accepted a
mission from a guy who I didn't really
follow what was happening and there were
options for kind of double crossing or
the way that you wanted to approach it
seemed very different and this isn't new
for the witcha I kind of think the would
should - even leaned more heavily on
this aspect and the witcher 3 did so if
anyone who didn't play the widget - i
won't flush it out a little bit but you
can only avoid the final boss fight in
that game entirely by just saying the
right things and doing the right things
you can completely avoid fighting the
guy the choices in that game are very
very in-depth I feel like it's the same
way in cyberpunk so we met with someone
from the military who was just being
real rude made a deal she gave us what
we thought was money and then we headed
off to make a trade to buy a robot which
was kind of like a spider robot that can
like crawl on the ceiling and act as a
drum with the guys I was talking about
before when I called to have this really
optic faces and don't really look human
so that was like a matter of how do you
want to approach it do you want approach
it by shooting everyone do you want to
try and talk through it we could have
fought the military woman could have
been rude to her they were dialogue
options there and a significant amount
of variety in those dialogue options as
well so it seemed like you know even for
that one quest the two different parts
of it while you're talking to the
military and then you're going to the
base to get the bot
probably could have gone very very
differently even though there's still
part of the same question so I don't
know how many options there were but it
it seems pretty fleshed out and yeah
that brings us up to the cool combat
stuff that we started to see certain
abilities that would slow things down
brutal but headings again the combat is
like the one thing that it seems really
creative and the wild traversal seems
really cool but I feel like I really
need to play it myself to tell you if I
like it or not I genuinely don't know it
looks a little white to me I want to say
but um I was impressed with the
creativity but just not sure how it'll
feel I really can't tell you so the only
other thing that I'm not sure about that
I guess I felt negatively about was
actually their writing it wasn't like it
was bad I was just it's not what I
expect from CD projects and that's
because it's very predictable and cheesy
stereotypical cyberpunk of course it
fits the setting of this world but it
was just like every character was just
like you're gonna get [ __ ] if you [ __ ]
me over I'll [ __ ] you over oh really
well what if I [ __ ] you over sit the
[ __ ] down
just everyone was like angry and gritty
and no one was really likable to me
including V it was just like stove in
your face Punk swearing that it didn't
really feel like any of the characters
were real they felt like archetypes with
the exception of Jackie who is you know
yo seemingly you like right-hand man and
he had a lot more personality than the
others dude there are a lot of
comparisons people have had with
cyberpunk and GTA after seeing and I
totally agree with that it feels more
like a GTA open-world kind of mix with
Bioshock but set in a very different
very impressive future but a lot of GTA
characters are also really likable and
really unique so I'm hoping the writings
the thing that they can change and work
on the voice acting as well because that
kind of like added to that cheesiness
but I didn't find any of the characters
relatable it is also hard to do that
from an ala um word people will be angry
at me for saying anything negative about
a game you're excited about but I want
to be honest and I didn't like no man's
sky before it came out and people were
mad at me for that I said I didn't like
Mass Effect Andromeda before I came out
people were mad at me from hat so like
kind of like so I just want to stick to
my guns on this a bit
I didn't think the writing was great
everything else looks really impressive
and I really do think the reason that
people are slow blown away by it is
because of the world and how big and
full and real it is this feels like the
future of video games in a way that it
feels like the closest thing that we've
had to an actual simulation of a
completely different world feeling fully
real now I want to talk about why I
think it's going to be banned in
Australia and also some of the
comparisons to it
go hand in hand it's drug use sure it's
violent I don't think it's violent
enough they don't get banned in
Australia that's not usually a thing
Israeli has issues with sexual violence
not just combat violence did not see any
sexual violence did see a lot of boob
that the naked lady that you rescued to
the side off I mentioned edges just a
lot of boob she's quite naked so the
first like 15 minutes of the demo just a
nipple on streaky was well animated so
the drug use is even similar to judge
shirt as well they take like a count
puffer thing that gives them certain
abilities or like he was using it when
she had her optics upgraded I assume
it's some kind of antibiotic like a
system that works to like let the body
kind of not would that it was also a
part of the demo where we took one as a
performance enhancer before heading out
into combat which is very similar to the
way that potions walk in the witch more
so in one and two and three as well but
you have to do a lot of prep and
thinking about what you're going to do
before you enter a situation that could
have comment and that's what this felt
like it felt like that same coughing
that CD Projekt has really always sort
of been about is a lot of being
meticulous and thinking about what
you're doing and combat rather than just
running in I'm sure there are many
variants of abilities on that but
because it is blatant drug use and
that's a huge thing that Australia has a
problem with the classifications board I
legitimately do not think the game will
be released in Australia at the very
least they will have to also those drugs
in some way alter the way that they are
used in a certain way and I think that
that's pretty much everything um ok
there are a couple of things I need to
add to this because I just realized that
I have this cyberpunk demo highlights
thing that I didn't know came with the
press kit so things that I did not
mention that there is
backstory creator you get to choose what
the backstory of your character is in
like a text adventure kind of way
similar to fire watch if any of you have
played that Jackie wells who was the guy
who's your right-hand man is a highly
skilled assassin dexta is what is called
a fixa he's the guy who gave you the
admission to get the bot he juggles
illegal contracts like burglaries
assassinations kidnappings and
trafficking and fixes are basically the
links between the mercenaries and the
clients and Dexter is like one of the
most important ones in the entire city
Royce is the gang known as the Maelstrom
he's that leader he's the one that works
for the gang that has all those tech
implants it says he raids corporate
transports and sells stolen tech on the
streets he's cold calculating and
distrustful dr. Victor is its Ripa doc
is the name of the people who will give
you upgrades for cyber we're so dr.
Victor is the guy that we saw in the
demo he was considered a half dog to
half engineer they can patch you up off
you've been messed up and tend to bullet
wounds if your tech is broken they can
fix it or install new stuff including
illegal wares and then the military is
what it's called the military agent
millet ech
that we met up with to make a deal with
is Meredith stout she's highly
successful she lives and breathes
corporate and she despises common folk
and spits all over people from lower
classes
hence what I'm saying about some cliches
there so all of your enhancements are
called cyber web including reflex
boosters and visual combat enhances like
a thermo scanner and then there's a part
where he talks about night city where it
says it comprises of six districts
beginning with its biggest pride at city
center the next one is Watson which is a
unique mix of Asian cultures it's a
fallen corporate giant now populated by
immigrants with bazaars and markets and
narrow alleyways and all that kind of
stuff
Westbrook is an area for the wealthy who
like to walk in potty that features a
tourist orientated Japan town Haywood is
a Latino area that means you
successfully managed to climb the social
ladder it's a huge suburban housing
district with an underlying gang problem
and then Pacifica which is the most
dangerous part of town abandoned
by gang activity separate separated from
the rest of the city it's a place of
immense poverty I think that's where the
opening part was set and it just says at
the antia a heavy element of cyberpunk
2077 is vertical exploration for example
visas apartment from the demo is located
at a mega building with multiple floors
each floor is home to many NPCs secrets
and potential quests players can explore
the city by car and motorcycle vehicular
combat with destructible cause is
possible in the game let me know if you
have any more questions I'll try to
answer all the ones that I can in the
comments but you guys it was my game of
show it's the best thing that I saw at
e3 this year that I was so blown away by
that world I feel like this game is
probably three years away I don't be out
anytime soon but maybe they could
surprise me they did say that currently
planning to bring out on current gen
consoles I just I don't feel like the
hardware could handle it okay I'm Alana
huge thanks to everyone whose names are
on screen right now it's putting me on
patreon I hope you all had an awesome
III thanks to everyone who watched all
of our coverage I am so [ __ ]
exhausted but it was so much fun and I
will see you all next time nothing